what is a t-test for dependent samples
the t-test for dependent samples tests
whether the mean values of two dependent
samples significantly differ from each
other for dependent samples the measured
values are in pairs the pairs result for
example from measurement repetitions
with the same persons an example you
want to find out if vacations have an
impact on people's stress level you
prepared a small questionnaire in the
questionnaire you ask persons before and
after the vacation about the stress
level if you interview the same people
before and after the vacation this is a
dependent sample but what other
hypotheses being tested the null
hypothesis is there is no significant
difference between the means of the two
dependent groups the alternative
hypothesis there is a significant
difference between the means of the two
dependent groups